- Hi everyone.
Sal Khan here and I'm with
Iman Howard, who is our manager
for all of our stem
content on Khan Academy.
And we wanted to welcome you
to the Middle school Earth
and Space Sciences course.
Iman, why should folks
be excited about this?
- So Middle school Earth and Space Science
is really exciting
because it's one of those areas
of science that answers what's
happening in our universe.
And then like when you dig in, you're like
"What is happening in our universe?
This is why we have seasons."
And so we start like really
big, we go all the way
to outer space and we figure
out sort of earth's position
in our solar system and the relationship
to gravity and our inner
planets and our outer planets.
And then we keep digging
in and we finally figure
out how Earth's position answers seasons.
It's not because we get closer to the sun
or how based on earth's
position, we look up at the moon
and you'll see a lunar eclipse
or how you don't look up
and look at a solar
eclipse, like seriously
don't look up because
it'll hurt your corneas.
And then we keep going
and we talk about water
and how the same water
that you're drinking right
now is the exact same
water that dinosaurs drink.
And then we get into the
rock cycle and we figure
out why mountains are here and
how we're moving right now.
Literally the plates below
us are moving and how
at one point we could walk
across all the way from the US
to Africa and how plate
tectonics really changed that.
And then finally,
finally, we talk about us.
We talk about us on this planet
and how there's so many amazing
resources here and how well
how we use them really impacts the earth
and how that could impact our climate.
And really awesome things that you can do
as a learner to change all that
and make this earth really awesome.
What are you excited about, Sal?
- Well, I'll just double
down everything you said
and I like how you said
we're gonna dig into it
'cause it's very appropriate
pun for earth, earth and space.
This starts to answer the questions of,
the from the cosmos to earth.
Over billions of years, as you
mentioned, the earth is alive
in certain ways with the
plates are still moving
it's active and we should
say at least, and you know
we are part of the earth.
Your point, the, the water in our bodies
the air that we breathe,
it's the same water
and earth that has been
been here and the air
for billions and billions of years.
So to be able to actually
understand that it,
it actually gives me, gives me goosebumps.
So I think folks will be very
excited about this course.
- Absolutely.
(upbeat music)